ABJAD: Thanks
everyone for coming.
My name's Abjad.
I lead one of the
product teams in ads.
And some of you guys
I've worked with
and are probably
wondering why I'm up here.
Mike and I actually grew up
together a long, long time ago.
Before he became the
renowned explorer is,
we were doing timetables
and addition and basic math
together.
And we've been talking over
the last year about a timeframe
for him to come in and share
some of his experiences
with folks at Google.
And I'm really excited to
welcome him here today.
And he's gonna spend about 45
minutes with us, walking us
through some of
his recent treks,
and then we've got some
time as well for Q&A.
So without any delay,
I'd like to introduce
Mike Libecki to you.
MIKE LIBECKI: Thanks, thanks.
All right.
You guys hear me OK?
All right, great.
Well, thanks for hanging
out, and for those of you
in on your computers,
however you're
watching, and then those
of you in the audience,
thanks for being here.
So I guess one of
the ways to put
it is I'm first and
foremost a father,
but I'm also an
obsessed/addicted
explorer-climber but
specializing in first ascent.
So the expeditions
and climbs that I do
are to places that
no one's ever been
to before, that are
completely unknown, untouched,
and that, gosh, exploration
is still very much alive,
and there are a lot of places
where no one's been to or seen,
especially that have big
rock walls, and towers,
and mountains.
So I'm going to get more
into that during the show,
so let me just give you
a little preview of what
we're gonna see today.
We're going to
place in Antarctica
that's incredibly remote.
And the nearest major city
is about 2,300 miles away
from this area, so it's one
of the most remote, if not
the most remote,
big wall area you
can go climbing on the planet.
And let me just give you
a little preview of that.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-This is like the SWAT team,
special weapons and tactics.
It'll be spicy for sure.
-It's a beautiful sunny day.
Dead calm, no wind.
Super dry.
Shuttled a load across the
ice cap, maybe t-shirts,
bronze a little bit
before we go home
for the wives and girlfriends.
Loving life.
-Yeah!
-Loving life!
-Antarctica bitches!
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So this is a very unique place
on the planet, but like I said,
also for Antarctica.
And I've done about 65
expeditions around the world.
I think technically
67, if I really
started counting them up.
And Antarctica is very
unique, obviously,
because it's really cool.
And I love places
that are really cold,
compared to the
extreme heat or jungle,
you don't have scorpions,
or snakes, or spiders.
So it's really nice
to be really cold.
Even if it's minus 30, minus
40, minus 50, you can get warm
and you can actually function
in this type of weather
rather than extreme heat.
So it's a very special place.
To go on an expedition
like this in Antarctica,
especially a place that
no one has been to before,
you can't just charter a plane.
And you can't just go
down there and do this.
It takes a lot of experience
and a lot of research,
but also permission.
There's an Antarctic
Treaty, and you
have to basically go by the
protocol of this treaty.
So you have to get
permission from the NSF,
the EPA, the State Department.
I think I submitted
52 pages of what
we were gonna do there to
all of these departments
to get permission
to go down there.
So it's not just a free for all.
The Antarctic Treaty.
It's really taking
care of Antarctica,
and making it our last
pristine continent,
and trying to keep it that way.
So this was a
really special trip,
in the fact that it's
expensive as hell.
And so I proposed this trip
to National Geographic.
So it's a big shout out
to National Geographic
for making the trip
possible, because it's really
incredibly expensive to go
down and do this kind of thing.
I love Antarctica,
because on most maps
that you see it's
not even on the map.
So it's just down at the
bottom of the Earth, kind of
forgotten in this world.
But it's one of the most
beautiful places I've been to.
I've been down
there seven times,
and some of the biggest rock
walls-- so these walls are not
ice, they're not snow.
These are big huge granite walls
that come out of the ice cap.
It's pretty spectacular,
and not many people
have seen these places.
This was really
unique in the fact
that the team going down
there, I got to choose the team
and figure out who's gonna go.
And so on the very right
hand side is Keith Ladzinski.
And if you check
him out online, he's
one of the best
videographers on the planet,
capturing just
extraordinary-- the way
he does things with
time lapse and video
is incredibly cutting edge.
It'll blow you guys away
if you check him out.
And that's Keith Ladzinski.
Next to him in the red
jacket is Corey Richards,
one of the best photographers on
the planet, National Geographic
photographer.
So Keith and Corey are coming
down to capture the trip,
and get everything behind the
scenes, in front of the scenes,
so we can share with people
like yourselves today.
And then in the blue jacket
is Freddie Wilkinson,
friend of mine.
And he's also my
climbing partner.
And he wrote an article for
National Geographic magazine
about this trip.
So it was really based
on going on this trip
to do something
really incredible,
but bringing back
the story to be
able to share on a global stage
with anyone who's interested.
And then I'm, of
course, on the left,
and I'm the
expedition leader who
proposed this trip,
who did the research,
and had been basically planning
this trip for eight years
until it finally
came to fruition.
So this was a really big
trip, long time in the making.
If you look in my eye there,
you can see these rock towers
reflecting out of my eye.
And I had been to this area by
myself eight years previous.
And so eight years ago,
before going on this trip,
I was down there by myself, and
made friends with some Russians
that you're gonna meet
here in a little bit.
And they flew me around
all these remote places
in their plane, and
I found these towers
that I've been trying
to get back to.
So we finally got down there.
In order to go to
this area Antarctica,
we're going with
a Russian company
out of Cape Town, South Africa.
And I thought this
was really unique.
If you see right
here, you can see
Antarctica on the flight board.
That's not very common
to be having a beer,
hanging out with
your friends, oh hey.
There's are flight to
Antarctica on the flight board.
Let's go.
Let's get on the plane.
And that was pretty unique.
That's the first year
that they put Antarctica
on the flight board in
Capetown, South Africa.
It was pretty funny.
I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: They
commercially fly there?
MIKE LIBECKI: It's
actually a charter flight,
but you have to go through
normal security now
to get on the flight.
So that was the first
year they did that.
The first time I'd been
down here was 2002,
and this is actually 2012,
when this trip happened.
So lots happening down there.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
NARRATOR: Their first stop,
a Russian research station,
Novolazarevskaya, or
Novo in Antarctica,
where they'll catch a short
flight to the Wohlthat
Mountains.
-So we fly into this old Russian
research station in Antarctica.
-Loving life!
-And then all of a
sudden, we're really here.
We're at the bottom
of the world,
and it's this
totally alien place.
And it's like we've
landed on the ice planet.
I can't wait to get
into the mountains.
But it looks like
we've got a problem.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So that problem is
called katabatic winds.
Does anyone know what
katabatic winds are in here?
Anyway, there are
crazy, crazy winds
that come from the South
Pole, and are pushed up
towards the coast.
These can be 80, 90, 100,
120 mile an hour winds.
So we took this
giant Aleutian 76
from Capetown down
to the Russian base
called Novolazarevskaza.
I mean, kind of like a
modern day Millennium Falcon
sort of aircraft.
And it's pretty cool when
you're flying over the ocean
to get to Antarctica, you can
go to the front of the plane
and just look out the windows,
and it's just magnificent.
But we were in Capetown
waiting for our flight.
We were supposed to
be there for two days.
We ended up being
delayed about two weeks,
because the katabatic winds
were just scouring the base,
and we couldn't go
down and land safely.
And they land this monster
aircraft right on the ice.
That's the tarmac.
It's just solid blue ice.
I mean, it's pretty incredible.
But we did get to
the Russian base,
and about two hours later,
the winds kicked up again,
and we've got these 60,
70, 80 mile an hour winds.
And this is just around
Novolazarevskaya.
There's a lot of Russians
hanging around, just
keeping the base going.
The reason this base exists is
because on this big Aleutian 76
flight, you've got Germans,
Norwegians, Japanese.
A lot of different
government organizations
come down to this Russian base,
and then small feeder flights
take them out to other
their government bases.
So it's basically a
government run operation,
and we're just these
climbers hitchhiking on board
to go down there.
And for a while, the
weather was pretty crazy.
We helped out
shovelling and just
living down here at the base.
And then we do need
to take these smaller
flights from the Russian
base out to the mountains
at this point.
And this is really
unique, because they
bring these planes.
Basically they're
Basler 67s, and they're
converted into DC3s.
They're flown all the
way down from Canada,
through South America,
into Antarctica,
and over to the
Russian base to meet
us and the other
government organizations
to fly out to the mountains.
It's a huge operation
going down here.
But we're at the Russian
base, and I'm thinking,
OK, I've proposed this
to National Geographic.
This is one of the
biggest expeditions
for myself and the team, but
also for today's modern day
and age of exploration.
I mean, it just doesn't
get more remote,
and the logistics
don't get more intense
than it does for
this kind of trip,
especially for first ascents
and vertical exploration.
So finally, this is a
really cool pivotal part
of the story and
one of the things
I love about expeditions,
just the mystery.
You never know what's
gonna happen next.
The pilots are from
Canada, and there
was this guy named Louis there.
And technically, they're not
allowed to fly these planes out
if the winds are more than
20, 30 miles an hour tops.
So we've got 40, 50,
60 mile an hour winds.
We're stuck at the Russian
base, and we're thinking, gosh,
our trip's over expeditions.
The expedition's over.
One of the biggest trips of our
lives, and we can't even move.
We're almost delayed 15,
16 days at this point.
Well, Louis, he
said, hey, you guys.
Let's get all the
gear in the plane.
And if we get a little weather
window, I'll try to take off.
We'll get you out
to these mountains.
We didn't get a weather window.
We had all these crazy winds,
and he said, you know what?
I'm gonna get paid anyway.
I could just be sitting
here and do nothing,
but I'm gonna get you
guys out to the mountains.
So I think it was about
40 mile an hour winds,
and Louis's like,
we're going for it.
So we took off.
We were kind of freaking out.
The plane's sliding
all over the ice.
And we got up in the air, and
we were out to the mountains.
So thanks to the Canadian
Louis, this amazing pilot
risking his life and,
of course, our lives
as well, to get out
to the mountains,
we were all in at this point.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
So the time is now.
We go for this.
-Here we go.
Throttle up.
-We decided to go
for it and took off.
It's a really alien landscape.
We could be looking out
of the window at Mars,
for better or worse.
Hundreds of mountains
that are unclimbed.
-We could go over
there, but it seems
like we've got some stuff
we could get done here.
Oh, look at that beautiful
summit over there.
Woohoo!
-The feeling of isolation
kicked in immediately.
You were watching the last
piece of comfort and warmth
just take off into the sky.
And then all of a sudden,
it got dead silent.
We built six foot high
walls 360 degrees.
We could not have flown in
a smaller weather window.
-And we knew life
was about to be very
different for the next 45 days.
-We asked for adventure,
and that's what we got.
And so it's only begun, man.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MIKE LIBECKI: So if you
noticed in these photos here,
there's a lot of blue ice.
And that basically is evidence
of the katabatic winds.
And so all the other places
I've been to in Antarctica,
there's always snow,
a lot of white snow.
So you notice it's just
blue, hard, clear ice.
And this is technically
one of the windiest places
on the planet, where
these katabatic winds just
scour the ice cap.
And so we've got
some big challenges.
It's one thing to
go out and survive.
That's no problem.
But to go out and try to
climb these vertical towers
is a whole new equation in front
of us, not just on its own,
but with the katabatic winds.
They're basically the biggest
enemy aside from rock fall
to go out and climb like this.
Cold is one thing.
You can deal with that.
But the winds kick up, you can
be frozen a matter of hours
if you're not prepared.
And of course with
that wind, though,
comes beauty and
art of the planet.
I mean, these winds
sculpted areas
that we just walked
around and were in awe of.
It was incredible.
And so imagine living
for almost two months
in temperatures colder
than your freezer at home.
So you have to adapt to that.
I have a lot of
experience in the cold,
and I think for a
couple of these guys,
it was a big wake up call.
Yeah, it takes a little
while to acclimate.
And so you can see
Corey, he broke his fork
because it was frozen.
He also broke his tooth.
And if Corey was
here, he would say
he always heard a banjo
playing in the background
with that broken tooth.
But he took a bite of a frozen
candy bar and broke his tooth.
You gotta be careful
when you're in the cold.
So basically what
we're gonna do is,
we're gonna go down here
to this mountain area,
and we're gonna circumnavigate
one of the small sections
of the mountain range.
And the reason we're
doing that is we're
coming down to find the
most remote, the biggest
vertical unclimbed
formations on the planet.
But to do that, to climb
one of these towers, yeah,
there's this huge
rock towers, but you
have to have cracks
and features to climb.
So we're scouting out an
area to actually find a route
that we can actually climb.
And there's a really cool
way to travel in Antarctica.
Usually, you'll take your skis,
and you'll take your kites,
and you'll use the winds
just to cruise around.
And we can just harness the
wind's energy and cruise
around this mountain range.
I've done this
easily for thousands
of miles just in my
lifetime, kite-skiing,
enjoying, having a good time.
But with these katabatic
winds that I mentioned,
we went out to set up our kites,
and we had the appropriate size
kite for the wind.
It was about 20,
25 miles an hour.
By the time we got
our kites set up,
we're hitting 40,
50 mile an hour
gusts, which weren't right
for these size of kites.
So basically when
you're kite-skiing,
you have different sizes of
kites for the amount of wind
that you have that day.
So if it's heavy winds,
these really small kites.
Really low five
mile an hour winds,
you have these big huge
kites to harness the energy.
And so we just went for
it anyway with the kites
we had out, and it
got real really fast.
It was pretty intense.
So this is either working way
too well or not working at all.
We went for it, and
it was pretty intense.
Next thing we knew, basically
there was a mechanism.
You have a bar.
You can cut the bar, and
the kite will go down.
It's a safety call.
You can get out the situation.
Well, the winds were so crazy
I had to cut my kite down.
I was still being
dragged across the ice,
and had to cut loose completely.
And here I am trying
to capture my kite,
so we don't litter
Antarctica, we're
within the protocol of
the Antarctic Treaty.
But I did capture my kite as
it was blowing off in the wind.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Just holding it,
and then just bam.
It'll go down.
-OK.
-In watching Mike
take off, as soon
as the wind picked up his
canopy and he shot out of there
like a slingshot,
immediately we realized
this was a terrible idea.
So we strapped our skins back
on, and just started trekking.
As the sun was setting, this
really heavy storm kicked in.
Immediately, we had to
start working together
as a team, digging
in hard and fast.
The only thing we could find
was this really tiny boulder
that we could take
shelter behind.
-We've got about
three foot drift
in our vestibule, the
front door of our tent,
that I had to dig out.
The winds super high,
and we're just trying
to deal head down, sufferfest.
Just trying to survive for
than anything else right now.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MIKE LIBECKI: The nice thing
about doing this ski tour
around this small
part of the mountain
range, this circumnavigation,
if you will,
was it took us about seven days.
It was about 100 miles.
And we've been able to acclimate
and get used to the wind.
And I know a couple of
the team members are like,
this is impossible.
There's no way we can climb
in this kind of temperature
and in this kind of wind.
I agreed with them.
It is impossible to climb when
you're in these kind of winds,
because you cannot
stay warm enough.
You have to be in a
sleeping bag or in a shelter
to actually stay warm enough.
But then there's
this whole thing
that happens on expeditions.
And it's like, when life
looks like Easy Street,
there's danger at your door.
There's a lot of mystery.
Without mystery,
there's no adventure.
And we planned to ski
around this mountain range,
but we couldn't even do that,
because it all just ended up
being that blue ice.
Even with full skins on
the bottom of your skis
for traction, for backcountry
use, even on the flats,
we couldn't do that.
So we ended up just having to
walk about 90+% of the way with
our crampons, which are
the spikes on the bottom
of your boots.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Day three of our ski tour,
just getting ready to go
see what's around the corner
on this huge, massive blue ice
plateau.
It's like being on the
coast of a frozen ocean.
We were all shocked to stumble
upon this Indian capsule
out in the middle of nowhere.
-You can see this
survival shelter
and this living unit
was just bowled over
by 150 mile an hours winds.
Who knows?
Maybe stronger.
Definitely makes you feel
a little bit vulnerable,
a fragile human out here.
We could just be
taken out at any time.
No doubt about it.
-The weather here, it's
raw, and it's brutal,
and it just beats
the shit out of you.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MIKE LIBECKI: You know,
on these expeditions,
sometimes you just
gotta go for it.
And Keith Ladzinski, who's
doing all the videography here,
he had never been
on skis in his life.
So he'd never put on ski
boots, and it was the situation
where it's like, just go.
It'll be fine.
You'll work it out.
And of course, as some of
you know from ski boots,
you can get blisters really
quick if you're not used to it.
So especially where we're at
now, we're out in the field,
this is absolutely 100%,
about self-reliance.
So we're on our own here.
If we need a rescue,
it's not gonna
happen unless the
weather's perfect.
I mean, maybe within a week
if we need a major rescue,
we can get someone out
there, but we're on our own.
This is full self-reliance.
Fortunately, this blister is
pretty much the worst injury
that we had the entire time.
Besides some frostbite
here and there,
we didn't have any
major injuries.
So we left on the ski tour.
We were gone for a week,
just about 100 miles
of cruising around
and looking for these,
basically, routes on
these towers, which we did
find, and I'll show you soon.
But those katabatic winds,
I've made these wind walls
on a lot of
expeditions, and they've
worked every single time.
Well, we left our camp set up
a little bit inside the walls.
I'm like hey, guys,
don't worry about it.
Everything will be fine.
But these winds
proved to basically,
when life looks
like Easy Street,
there's danger at your door.
Member that again.
That's gonna come
up a few times.
Well, here's before, and
here's what those winds
can do to your camp.
Well, you'd better like
digging, because we're gonna
be doing a lot of digging.
I mentioned self-reliance.
We've got extra tents,
extra stoves, extra gear.
We've got it all
flagged out, where
if we did get buried like this,
we were prepared for this.
We thought about
these things ahead.
Again, that 100% self-reliance
is very real out here.
So it was pretty interesting.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The crazy thing
is it hasn't snowed
an inch since we've been here.
That's all wind-driven snow.
-Savage dude.
-Pretty savage.
Look at this.
-Real deal, man.
Antarctica.
It's Thanksgiving.
We're so thankful for the
sweetness of life, man.
-This is Thanksgiving.
Instant mashed potatoes
with lots of butter.
-Woohoo!
-We dug out and we
picked up the pieces,
and realized we had
to find a safer base
camp, a place that
we could really
rely on in the worst weather
that Antarctica throws at us.
-Well, that one jusy has like
a perfect cooking zone with
the protected--
-We had to move our camp
over near the tower,
in the rocks, where
it's much safer, where
we have a lot more protection
from the katabatic winds.
-We found a great spot here
in the boulders, nestled,
living with the snow
petrels and the skuas.
Two beautiful spires
right above us.
The hour is almost here
when we get to climb.
-Happy birthday, Freddie.
-It's my birthday, and it's
the first pitch of the trip.
-Have fun, be safe, love life.
-Yeah.
-We're up for one of the
biggest challenges of our lives,
to just get up to the
top of this tower.
It's gonna be an incredible
feat for us to all come together
and make it to the top.
-Little rocks coming.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MIKE LIBECKI: So we didn't
just start climbing.
Before that, we got
our camp moved over.
We got hit by another several
days of wind and mayhem.
And it reminds me
that there's basically
two different ways I see that
you experience an expedition.
And it correlates to
just everyday life.
And as an utter optimist, the
way I look at is, there's joy.
We have a lot of joy in life
every day, the pursuit of joy.
Well, you also have
what's called pre-joy.
And this is basically
when life is shitty,
and it's really f-ing cold.
So I look at it as you either
have pre-joy, or you have joy.
And so if you have
pre-joy, at least you
have the word joy in there,
and you know joy is coming.
But that's more
strange mentality
things from being on too
many expeditions, I think.
If you don't have utter
optimism out there,
and you don't believe in what
you can do, you're gonna fail.
If you're not having fun
and you wanna be there,
you're not gonna make it.
So without that utter optimism
of pre-joy or joy, joy
it doesn't work for me.
But we finally did
get to our new camp.
As you can see, we're
starting to climb.
And we've just got endless
variables and constants
to this equation.
You know, the most
important part
of this expedition or any
major expedition is packing.
So when you're back at
your garage or your home,
and you're putting all
this gear together,
if you forget that one
little tool, for example,
to fix your stove,
your expedition's
over, maybe your life.
So if you forget anything like
that, even the climbing gear,
here one little thing could
disrupt the entire equation
to that final
product of the summit
of the climb, the goal
of the expedition,
or just even coming home alive.
So we started shuttling all the
gear to the base of the wall.
Behind the scenes work,
days and days and days,
we're just carrying heavy
loads, getting up to the route.
And we did find a really
cool route, by the way.
You can see down here it's Keith
Ladzinski walking a little guy
in.
This is the tower that we chose.
This is the biggest
tower in the area.
And the beautiful thing about
this tower, as a climber,
you always want to find
these cracks on these walls.
OK, this is a beautiful tower.
There's hundreds
if not thousands
of these towers
around the world that
are just incredible like this.
But a lot of them
don't have cracks.
Right up here there's
a crack system that
goes all the way up this tower.
I mean, it's like God used to
be or is a climber in a way.
I mean, a perfect crack system
that goes all the way up.
It was just incredible.
And this is an example
of foreshortening.
And you can see the
top third of the tower,
and Freddie here is on the
first pitch of the climb
about halfway up.
So when you see things in
the Arctic or Antarctic,
like big towers
like this, you don't
have trees or houses or cars
or anything to compare it to.
Sometimes, these
walls look small.
And then it looks really big.
Well, we realized we
have a really long way
to go up this tower.
And one of the key points here
for climbing in Antarctica,
especially in this area
of katabatic winds,
is good weather.
So we would climb
for a day or two,
and then we'd get three
or four days of wind
and be shut down
and in our tents.
Well, this was a beautiful day.
No wind.
And of course we have
24 hour sunlight.
This is the spring and
summer down in Antarctica.
And so we'd climb for
25, 30 hours of the time,
taking advantage of
the good weather,
because we knew that horrible
weather was coming back.
And we're fixing
our ropes anchor
to anchor at this point because
of the weather and the cold.
We don't have a choice.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-This tower has an
amazing crack system
going from bottom to top.
It's the biggest,
proudest, most formidable
aspect of the mountain.
-This is a kind of climbing that
I've never experienced before.
It's a kind of rock quality
and featured face of rock
that I've never experienced.
So far it's just
been fascinating.
It's been really scary.
-Heads up.
Rock, rock.
-Whoa, dude.
-What really
concerns both Libecki
and I is this huge
refrigerator sized deadblock
about 15 feet above the belay.
-It really is making for a
unique, challenging climb
to negotiate this kind
of terrain safely.
-See what a trippy
landscape this is?
-Yes.
-It's like Doctor Seuss
rock-- sounds hollow,
sounds like it'll break.
If it does break, you're gonna
fall a long way, because it's
very hard to protect.
There aren't a lot of cracks.
It's really spooky climbing.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MIKE LIBECKI: So it was
really, really spooky,
to say the least.
It was actually incredibly
frightening to climb
this kind of rock.
Now, I think a lot of you are
climbers, or have climbed,
or know about climbing.
If you fall on a rope, it's
really usually no big deal.
I mean, this is holding 12,
13, 14,000 pounds of weight,
a lot of kilonewtons,
force, motion.
I mean, these ropes are strong.
This kind of climbing was
different because of the rock
quality.
I was kind of like climbing
on big potato chips and corn
flakes.
And then of course, all the
little edges of this rock
is really sharp.
So you don't want to
fall and cut the rope.
And that was on the
back of our minds.
There weren't gonna to be
a lot of clean falls here.
The rock did get
really steep, and I'll
get into that in a minute.
And that made it a
little bit safer,
but the rock was so sharp
because the temperature
variance in Antarctica is so
intense, and the winds here.
So the surface of the rock
is just really, really crazy.
Again, it felt like being
on giant potato chips,
like on a giant corn flake.
It was really sharp
on your fingers.
It was really wild.
Very raw, cold feeling of rock.
So this is Freddie
racking up here,
and taking a lot of weight.
You've got two or three
layers of clothing.
You've got jackets,
big jackets over it.
And you've got 30,
40 pounds of gear.
I mean, everything gets really
heavy really fast down here,
because you're
basically never warm.
You're just warm
enough to climb.
So when we're out climbing
and out in the elements,
we're just warm enough
to function and climb.
The only time you're truly
warm is in your sleeping bag
or your tent back at base camp.
But as I mentioned, the
rock got really steep.
So this wall was
incredibly steep,
and it was really beautiful,
because it got safer.
It was more intense,
and exposed,
and scary the steeper it gets.
But if you take a fall, it's
gonna fall out into space,
and you're gonna stay
away from that rock, which
is pretty nice, actually.
And this is a shot
of me climbing here,
and Corey Richards is
above me, taking down
the shots from above to get for
the magazine and share the cool
ways that we do this.
And at that point, it was
like, we can't do this anymore.
It's too dangerous.
We've gotta focus on the climb.
We've gotta focus
on the objective.
And doing a lot of the rigging
and getting different camera
angles was just getting too
dangerous because of the wind,
because of the rock quality.
We had to focus on safety
and our goal ahead.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I think for every
day that we've
been able to
actually climb, we've
had two days of heavy,
strong, katabatic winds.
So it's been a
real challenge just
to continue to
progress up the wall.
But now we're at a point at
a really big natural ledge
up there.
-And it's within striking
distance of the top.
We guess there's
maybe 800 feet to go.
-We're gonna move our camp up
to the high camp on the wall,
and try to get to the
summit from there.
-So life's about to change.
It's gonna get
pretty blue collar.
Hauling our supplies
up to that ledge
will take a lot of effort,
and then living up there,
it won't be as comfortable
as down here in the boulders.
-This tower is controlling us.
It's commanding us.
And it's demanding us to
bring all of our experience
that all of us have together,
and focus it on this route.
It's commanding everything that
we have to make this possible.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MIKE LIBECKI: So
what we've been doing
is we've been fixing
ropes anchor to anchor.
And we're about 1,600 feet, all
our ropes connected together.
And this is called
capsule-style climbing.
And we had to climb slow
like this, as I mentioned,
because we'd climb for a while.
The winds would come
in for a couple days.
And then we'd have to go
back down to base camp.
So now we've hauled
all of our gear
up to the side of the wall.
We're gonna live on
the side of the wall
until we can get to the summit.
And we're living in this
port-a-ledge, this hanging
condo, so to speak.
And one thing in the back
of my mind at this point
is, if those winds kick up
up here, that hanging condo,
that port-a-ledge is gonna
turn into that ski-kite.
And it's gonna be shredded.
So in that equation that I
talked about of an expedition,
sometimes you just
hope for luck,
because there's nothing
else you can do.
So we're committed to the wall.
All of our ropes are
pulled up, and we're
gonna try to go to
the summit from here.
Fortunately, we had
a big natural ledge.
A lot of the times, you don't
get this big natural ledge
to stand on.
And to be honest,
that made it really
nice for going to the bathroom.
If you can imagine living
on the wall for a while,
you've gotta do everything
you do every day.
And to be quite frank, taking
a dump up there is not easy.
But when you have
a natural ledge,
it makes it way
easier than trying
to hang in your harness and--
Think about this.
Antarctic Treaty protocol.
We're capturing and
containing all of our feces
to take out with us when
we leave from Antarctica.
Four guys for almost two months,
that's of feces, a lot of stuff
to gather.
And it's not easy when you're
up in the vertical world.
But fortunately it freezes,
so it wasn't too bad.
So this was one of
the most intense parts
of the entire expedition.
I'm climbing up above
Freddie, and this is pushing
what's called A3 Plus, A4.
It's A Type of climbing,
because there's no cracks.
It's really cold.
Every few feet, I'm stomping
and I'm shaking out my fingers
so I can actually feel them.
And I'm using hooks on the rock.
We can talk about this
later, after if you want.
But if I fall, these pieces of
gear are not gonna catch me.
And I'm gonna to
go below Freddie,
and smash onto the horn
that's he's sitting on.
So this was a really spicy
type of climbing up here.
And fortunately, I was
able to climb this pitch
without falling, but
it was pretty scary,
because if I did
fall, it could have
endangered the entire team,
including myself, et cetera.
But it was a pretty
intense time.
And this is what it looked like,
leaving our port-a-ledge camp.
So it was really steep.
And as soon as you
clipped into the rope,
and you left the camp, you
swung out basically in space,
and you're looking a
couple thousand feet down.
You definitely did not need
coffee in the morning to wake
up.
You were just like,
I'm ready to go.
Because it was quite intense.
And you're thinking, well,
at least I was thinking,
OK, that rope is
coming from above.
If the winds kick that rope over
on a little sharp piece of rock
the night before,
and I'm going up
this rope to get
to the high point,
that rope's gonna saw in half.
So the way I see it,
what we are doing
is 100% mathematically safe.
You just can't make a mistake.
So that rope had to be placed
with directionals and rope
protectors, and put in an exact
place that could not move.
And if we made that
mistake to not do that,
that rope would have
been moved by the wind
and sawed in half
as we're going up.
I mean, there's
endless things to think
about in this situation to make
it 100% mathematically safe,
which I have to believe
that it is, to be honest.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Snow, sun, snow, sun, that's
about what we're dealing with.
-For how serious and savage
an environment it is,
there is an equivalent
beauty just looking out
on this landscape of hundreds
of mountains that are unclimbed.
It never gets dark.
The mountains are just
24 hour a day sundials,
and the sun's just
spinning around them.
And there are
these snow petrels,
about the only living
life down here, that
just come in and hover,
and float in on updrafts
around the tower.
I think they're pretty
surprised to see us.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MIKE LIBECKI: It's
really wonderful to work
with people like Keith
Ladzinski or Corey Richards who
are capturing this, and
having a team follow along
to document the journey.
I mean, those are some
of my favorite parts,
seeing those snow petrels.
I mean, they were so beautiful.
This is a good example of
what the rock was like.
You can see.
We're on smaller screens
here, but Freddie's
down here in the
green belaying me,
and I'm up here in
the red in this crack.
That's about 100 feet.
So that's about half a pitch.
And if you look at
the size of Freddie,
you can barely see him.
And look at the skyline here.
You can see those potato chips
and this corn flakes of rock.
It really was just the wildest
rock I've ever been on.
And so this part
where we're at here,
we're just about halfway
up this tower right there
for some perspective.
Now, as we're getting
up closer to the summit,
we're getting pretty excited,
because, OK, we might make it.
The wind has been working
with us a little bit.
We might just make
it to the summit.
If we get hit by a
crazy storm, we're
probably gonna have to go down.
So we're thinking, OK, if we can
get up in the next day or two
without any wind, we're cool.
But as we're getting up, the
angle of the rock kicks back.
And we're pulling
off 100 of flakes,
and it gets really dangerous.
So if you pull off
those rocks, they're
gonna go down on your partners
below, and kill them or cut
ropes.
So as we're getting
up, I'm like, OK, guys.
We can't continue on this route.
Because so much rock is coming
off someone's gonna die.
And so we're either
going down, or we're
gonna cut off and traverse,
and then try to it another way.
So fortunately, I
found some moves,
and we cut off to
the right, and we
were able to get
to the right ridge,
and eventually
get to the summit.
It's kind of hard to
see here, but here's
Corey, Freddie, and myself.
We cut off right, and then
made route to the right ridge.
And that was really
fortunate for us,
because I don't think we
could've continued on had we
not started traversing out.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Climbing the wall was an
extreme technical challenge.
It required a lot of gear, a
lot of time, a lot of effort.
-It was really
enjoyable climbing
on these big handholds, and
these big caves, and wacos,
and climbing through this
jungle gym kind of rock.
-You can easily give
it the standard ratings
throughout climbing
and mountaineering,
but it goes above
and beyond that.
It's mystery, because
it's a first ascent.
we climbed the steepest,
proudest line on the tower.
No doubt in my mind.
-Yeah.
-Sick.
-Hell yeah!
-Yo, yo, yo.
We're on the summit.
We're loving life,
and we're psyched.
We're in Antarctica,
and it kind of
feels like standing upside down
on the bottom of the Earth.
Awesome trip.
Life is sweet.
The time is now, and we're
hoping for a safe descent.
Over.
-Getting to the top,
it was a relief,
because I didn't wanna see
that all that time and effort
that we had invested in the
line and not be successful.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MIKE LIBECKI: So fortunately,
we did make it to the top.
It was really a
wonderful feeling
to be up there
with your friends.
Now, Keith is not with us.
Keith didn't go to
the top with us.
He stayed on the ground
to get all the ground
shots, both photo and video.
And so a big shout out to Keith
for staying down on the ground,
because I know he
wanted to go up with us,
but we all had a
different role there
that we were playing as
this expedition team,
especially for
National Geographic
to come back and bring this
story home in the best way
possible.
This is a little shout
out to Corey here.
Basically, I went
down there with Cory,
we had never met each other.
We met for the first time
in Capetown, South Africa.
I'd known Keith.
I'd known Freddie.
But when you go down on
expedition like this,
you don't know each other,
you can be chasing each other
with ice axes trying to kill
each other and be pissed off,
or you can fall in love and
make new friends for a lifetime.
Because going on
an expedition like
this really is like a short
term marriage, or even closer.
The trust and the bonds
that you make out there
are so special it's
even hard to describe.
I mean, you take
them with the rest
of your life with those bonds.
And basically because
Corey is like, here you go.
Here's my life.
I'm trusting you with my
life on this entire trip.
And then vice versa, I'm
giving my life to him.
He's giving his to
me, the whole team.
If I make a mistake,
that could cost his life.
And so it's pretty
intense out there.
And Corey's up there,
following us up the wall
with this camera.
And he's the last guy coming up
with all the rocks coming down.
And so just at the
big shout out to him.
There's three rules
of an expedition.
And you go with friends,
you go with friends,
you go with friends.
And it's always been like that.
So it was nice to step
out of those rules
and make a new friend,
and share those bonds
with someone you didn't know.
It was another part
of the expedition.
This is up on the summit, and
of course, Corey's like, yeah,
we're up there.
Right on.
And Freddie and I are
thinking, this is really cool.
It's been about 20 minutes,
but we've gotta go down.
And we're thinking about that
loose rock, the sharp rock.
We're gonna rappel
down the same route
that we climbed to get down.
So it's pretty intense up there.
I, of course, always
have my mask with me.
This was Year of the Dragon, so
the proper Chinese lunar year,
Chinese zodiac yeah, however
you wanna explain it,
but I always bring that
year's mask with me,
and it's just a fun way
to honestly just remind
myself and hopefully others that
don't take life too seriously.
And let's all not grow up.
Let's all keep our childhood
in us, and have some fun,
and laugh.
And really, just don't
take life too seriously,
and have some fun
with it, and enjoy it.
I mean, that's really
one of the things we
get to do on these expeditions.
It's sort of be like a
professional kid or something.
Really go out there and
live in the moment of now,
and celebrate life.
It's quite fascinating, and I
just can't get enough of it.
This is a 360 degree view of
the summit that Corey took.
It's just a beautiful
time up there.
And I talked about that wind.
We got lucky.
We have good weather for
the last several days.
And we haven't got
hit by a storm,
so we're kind of like, OK,
let's not push our luck.
Let's get down.
Let's get out of here.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-You get to the top,
and you're so excited,
but you know you're halfway.
The summit's on the ground.
-We're packing up the air pig.
-The airpig.
Explain the air pig.
-Well, there are pigs
built for hauling
and pigs built for airing.
This little piggy's gonna go
wee-wee-wee all the way down.
-One, two, three!
-Dude, that was a
great toss, man.
Like, the bag had a
big rip in it already.
-It was the perfect
soldier for it, huh?
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MIKE LIBECKI: So I work with
a lot of outdoor companies,
and I have for a long time.
And that's some pretty good
product testing right there
in such a way.
We just threw down some
of the trash and stuff
that it didn't
matter if it broke.
I mean, we took down all
of our climbing gear,
and all of the stuff that
was valuable and breakable,
we took it down with us.
And so we got back
down on the ground,
and just a few hours later,
we'd had that great weather
without the wind.
And as soon as we got down,
got back down to base camp,
it was kind of cool, because
we got nailed by a crazy storm.
And we're getting comfortable,
thinking oh, we made it.
We made the summit.
We're gonna be able
to get picked up.
The plane's gonna come out.
And then these winds
started kicking up,
and we're thinking,
gosh, if this goes on,
who knows how long
it's gonna go for?
Hopefully the planes can
come down and pick us up.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Looks like it could
get real today.
Snow, wind, and
katabatic mayhem.
Trying to save the penguin pig.
-Yeah, save the penguins.
-What a ridiculous scene.
-It's horrible.
-It's cold.
It's windy.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MIKE LIBECKI: A quick note.
If this wind would have hit us,
if this storm would have hit us
on the wall, I'm
just gonna say, quite
frankly, we would've
been fucked.
And that's an appropriate word.
We would've been hating life.
And again, that luck, that
part of the equation was--
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-It'll kill you in
a matter of hours.
-The wind has not stopped.
-Katabatic winds, yo.
It's getting real out here.
Freddie's tent
just got shredded.
He jumped into Corey's.
Man, it's getting real deal.
-We've been pretty
much tentbound
for going on four days
because of the winds.
-We hope we get picked
up for Christmas.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MIKE LIBECKI: So this expedition
was an incredible experience,
mainly because of the times that
we had out there as friends.
And the second best
part of any expedition
is being able to come
back and share it
with your friends, your family,
with people like yourselves,
and just know that magic, and
power, and beauty out there
that maybe not a lot of
people want to go experience,
or don't have the
opportunity to,
but want to see
what's out there.
And for me, it's an opportunity
to hopefully inspire people
just to get outside, maybe
inspire people to care more
about the planet, and start
thinking not only about caring
about the planet, but what are
the solutions for the planet
and the people around the
world, especially speaking
with and through
National Geographic that
made this trip possible.
It's been a very
selfish lifestyle of,
if you're gonna be a
doctor, or a lawyer,
or whatever, you immerse
yourself into that.
You take your passion
very seriously,
and you really immerse yourself
into what you're doing.
And hopefully, we can
start sharing these stories
on different levels and
get people more excited
about what's going on the
planet, on a local level,
on a global level, not just
the environment but also
the people around the world
that we can connect with.
For me, this was the
biggest trip of my life,
and one of the
biggest trips that I
could do in today's day and age
for exploration and climbing.
Yet, by the end of this trip,
it was like another training
session for the next one.
And all of these expeditions
become training for the next,
and the next, and the next.
And it really is an
obsession and addiction
to go out and explore
these areas and climb.
And one of the
things I really want
to note on, aside
from we're really
trying to inspire people to
just care about the planet more,
and to get out outside
more, and put down
your screens and your
phones, and just get out
in the moment of now and nature.
Because that's what it does
for me, when I'm outside,
and in nature, and
in remote places,
it really is that moment of now.
This tower here that we climbed,
this is the route that goes up.
And then we cut across,
and that was the summit.
This was a really special
expedition for me,
because I made a
decision to leave
college, my first year of
college, and climb full time.
And it was a really
big deal for my family.
What do you mean you're
gonna leave college?
All I can think
about is climbing.
I just wanna climb.
I moved into my truck.
I was climbing 300 days a year.
The one main supporter that
I had for this decision
was my grandmother.
And I went over, and I said,
all I wanna do is climb.
I wanna move to
Yosemite National Park.
I grew up in Fresno, Clovis,
with some friends here.
And so Yosemite, the center of
the universe, is right near us,
and I started climbing.
So I moved to Yosemite.
I left college.
I was living in my truck.
But my grandmother,
she sat me down.
She poured a couple
glasses of whisky.
She got really excited.
And she said, god damn it,
Michael, you need to go climb.
You need to live your life.
And she didn't get
to go to school.
She had nine
brothers and sisters,
and she worked on a farm.
And if they didn't work on
the farm, they didn't eat.
So for a long time,
she was so supportive.
And I kind of felt like I
was living some of her dreams
through my life.
And any time I got home
from an expedition,
I went right to her house,
and she'd make BLTs.
And I grew up with her, and
we had this strong connection.
Well, just before leaving
on this trip to Antarctica,
she passed away.
And it was a big deal for me,
and our family, and everyone.
And it was so close.
And so in the
climbing world, you
get to name the mountains you
climb if it's a first ascent.
So we got to name this
tower Bertha's Tower
after my grandmother.
And it was just a very
special honor for her,
that 20 years later,
her encouragement
to go out and pursue
my passion and she'd
passed away right before this,
and to honor her on this climb,
on this expedition,
her life, and that's
one of the things I
wanted to share with you,
just how powerful
these expeditions are.
And I think with that,
thanks for watching.
And I appreciate your
guys attention today.
So
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thanks, Mike.
Man, that was awesome.
MIKE LIBECKI: Cool.
Thanks, man.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for coming.
That was just beyond what
I expected to come today.
MIKE LIBECKI: Awesome.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
sharing about your grandmother.
It was very touching.
You mentioned the winds
when they kick up.
And when you're
up on the mountain
that you're in big
trouble, basically.
So what's that process in your
mind, where you say, that's
an uncontrolled variable, and
you just decide to go for it?
Knowing that if it kicks up and
you have no control over that,
what are you gonna do?
I'm just interested
in your mindset.
How do you get past that?
MIKE LIBECKI: This is a very
unique situation for the wind.
I've been on a lot of
trips with a lot of wind,
but this one was
completely unique.
We knew that 60, 70,
80, 90, 100 mile an hour
winds could come in and
freeze you pretty quick.
And so it was like
I said, the luck.
We were up on the wall, and
we're like, here we are.
Let's go for it.
Sometimes, you're just all
in, and you have to go for it.
And honestly, that
mystery is the adventure.
That not knowing and
not understanding
what's gonna happen next
is part of the drive,
part of the obsession
of doing this stuff.
And so if it was a
controlled environment,
and there was no
mystery, I don't think
that I would have any interest.
So every trip, every time,
going up on that wall,
knowing these winds could come
in, that mystery is the drive.
But it also connects to fear.
And fear is a wonderful
emotion, feeling, powerful thing
that you can experience.
And it's a tool to keep us safe,
because if we're not scared up
they're thinking about
it, we're probably
gonna get in a situation.
So having that fear also keeps
you safe in the same respect,
that we're prepared.
OK, you guys, what are we
gonna do if this happens?
If the winds kick up,
here's what we're gonna do.
Here's our Plan
A, Plan B, Plan C.
We're thinking
about this, talking
about it the whole time.
And I guess
communication is really
what saves us if that wind
comes up, that we're talking
about what's gonna happen.
What's gonna happen if this
happens and this happens?
if I do fall and someone breaks
a leg, what are we gonna do?
If the wind comes up,
here's what we're gonna do.
I hope that answers
the question.
It's a great one, because
it's intense, and it's scary.
But that wind
equals hypothermia.
So if it comes in, we're
gonna freeze really quick.
And sometimes you're
starting to get cold.
You have to predict
hypothermia before it happens,
because then you
can't move your hands
and put yourself on
rappel and get down.
So hey, guys.
It's getting really cold.
Let's get down now back
into our port-a-ledge
and get safe, because I
can barely move my fingers.
So without living
in the now, you
have to think about what's
gonna happen next a little bit.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I had
a couple questions.
One is how did you get around?
Are there good maps
of all these places?
And do you have GPS?
MIKE LIBECKI: There are some
good maps, Norwegian maps
made of the area.
Norway actually claims to
own this area in Antarctica,
but no one really
does officially.
So it's a world continent.
But there are some
good Norwegian maps
that helped incredibly well.
AUDIENCE: Was just curious
it about belaying was.
It's one thing to be
climbing and moving,
but to be at the back
of the anchor belaying,
I'm sure that was--
MIKE LIBECKI: That's a
great question, so asking
about how the belays were.
And to be totally honest,
when we're climbing up there,
and we're up in
the vertical world,
we're outside of our tents,
outside of our port-a-ledge,
the belayer is the
one who suffers.
Because you're sitting
there, and you're freezing.
And you're kicking your feet,
and you're moving your arms.
I mean, you're literally kicking
your feet the whole time,
and moving your arms,
and doing all this.
And the other guy's bringing
up a thermos of hot chocolate
so you can drink
it and stay warm.
I mean, it's a constant
battle to not freeze.
The climber, the leader, is
moving, and staying warm,
and generating.
That engine is running
and staying hot.
And so that's a great question.
The belayer is the one who
suffers because of the cold,
and also because of the
loose rock coming down.
And you're yelling,
rock, a lot of times,
and there's rock coming
all over the place.
And it's another luck factor.
No one got by any
of the big rocks.
None of the ropes got cut.
And sometimes, you
just hope for the best.
And I did mention, it's
100% mathematically safe.
I believe that, because we
made the right decisions,
and everything worked out.
So you could get me talking
all day about this stuff.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that you started your career
from climbing.
You left your college
and started to climb.
But how did you
turn from climbing
to traveling to exploring?
MIKE LIBECKI: So I ended
up moving to Yosemite,
and climbing there a lot.
And I really immersed myself
in the passion of climbing.
And living in Yosemite and
doing all different kinds
of climbing, I started
thinking, oh, I
wanna go to where
no one's climbed.
I think in human nature, we're
all explorers in some degree.
We all want to find the unknown.
We all want to do something
different for ourselves.
And I think the best way to
explain it is organic passion.
I don't know how I got
excited about doing it,
but I started doing
climbs that were
more remote in the Sierras,
in the backcountry,
and then finding out about
these walls and towers that
were around the world.
After my first trip to
Baffin Island, which
is up in the northern
Canadian Arctic,
and climbing these kinds of
walls for the first time,
where no one's ever
been to before,
it was like sticking
the needle in.
It was just like, I
can't get enough of this.
I was addicted to it.
I just wanted to go on these
trips, and I wanted to climb.
And it became this obsession.
And then I think following
that true passion turned into,
oh, I could write
stories about this,
and I can sell photos
to outdoor companies,
and there's a way to generate
a living around this passion.
And that was 20 plus years ago.
And so it really is a huge shout
out to the outdoor industry,
and to all the people involved
in making the products,
and the people that
enjoy recreation who
are buying all these products.
I mean, it's a big full
circle of the outdoor world
that we're all connected in.
And it's a great honor to be
able to do this for a living,
but also for a passion.
But it's because of the
countless people involved
that really make it happen.
AUDIENCE: I hope this
isn't too sensitive,
but how much does an
expedition like this cost?
MIKE LIBECKI: Well, I'll give
you a few details about this.
So, for example, I won't
go into to all the details
of what we spent,
but to get the plane
ride down from
Capetown to Antarctica,
that's $25,000 per person,
just for that flight.
The charter flight
from the Russian base
out to the mountains
was about $88,000.
That's just the flights alone.
That's not from
the US to Capetown.
That's not any of
the freight charges.
I mean, we had a
lot of equipment.
It
This is a very unique
trip in so many ways,
including how much it costs.
So I'm gonna come
back right and say it.
Without the support
of the amazing people
at National Geographic, this
kind of stuff doesn't happen.
I mean, we're just honored
to be able to have done this
and share this, but
it gets expensive.
But not all the trips
are even close to that,
but this one is
very, very unique.
AUDIENCE: A question,
you mentioned
at the start of your talk
about being a father.
So when you were
out there, what's
that like being away
from your daughter?
MIKE LIBECKI: I'll
talk to my daughter
about this, because
it's been interesting.
She's grown up with a
dad who is adventuring
and gone quite a lot.
And I've talked to her that
anything worth doing is gonna
have compromise and sacrifice.
And part of that
for what I'm doing
is I've gotta leave sometimes.
But on a cool note on that,
she is also becoming a traveler
and adventurer herself,
and it's pretty exciting.
But her mother is
amazing, and she's
been incredibly supportive.
Without the support of family
and friends, none of this stuff
could happen.
So it's not just me or
us up on these trips.
It's a whole, entire
group of people, hundreds
of people, that make it happen.
And I just wanna make that
clear how much I appreciate
that it just doesn't happen
without all the help of tons
of people.
But it's been tough as a dad,
having to leave and come back.
But one of the cool things that
I'll bring up, my daughter,
she's 12 years old.
She just went to her
seventh continent with me
this last summer in Africa.
She's been to 15
countries, and now she
wants to start doing these
expeditions as a humanitarian.
And she's saying, I
wanna do these trips,
and I wanna come up with
solutions for things
that we can better on
our planet and people.
So it's really exciting to
see her grabbing onto what
she's seen growing up.
It's really cool.
ABJAD: Great.
Thanks again, Mike, for coming
out and spending time with us.
And we'll get you to come
back maybe every year
with some new tales and new
stories over here at Google.
So thanks everyone
for joining us today.
MIKE LIBECKI: Awesome.
[APPLAUSE]